I can't wait to a nice work looks like  Vanderpump rules start Katie Maloney is  one step closer to say and I do to  fiance Tom Schwartz sources tell E teeth  at their wedding is set for august 15 in  Northern California and yes the Bravo  cameras will be there filming the big  day et can also confirm co-stars tom  sandoval ariana Maddox Jax Taylor and  girlfriend Brittany Cartwright will  attend the nuptials next month Katie  Maloney at eleven my life earlier this  month Katie celebrated her bridal shower  poolside with her friends and Bravo  co-stars and when et caught up with the  bride-to-be last year she suggested that  Tom take her name Katie Maloney has a  better ring my name oh I totally should  be very progressive and you take me  dancing hey Greg he doesn't like it